thanks to bones and all for sponsoring a
portion of this video
this is not video footage it's a render
but it looks pretty photo real right
like achieving this level of quality in
CGI would normally require a huge amount
of time and effort but what if I told
you that I easily made this in a matter
of minutes thanks to a brand new
technology called Nerf Nerf no not that
kind of Nerf no no not that one either
no I'm talking about neural Radiance
fields and in this video I'm going to
tell you how they're going to change
filmmaking forever
I've managed to make a career out of
experimenting with new technologies to
create short films and along the way
we've learned tons of tools such as deep
fakes virtual production and one of my
favorites 3D scanning little known fact
about photo scanning is that when Ren
does it he makes a very specific face
Ren would you like to show them the face
that you make when you photo scan there
it is it's the most serious face I've
ever seen on Reddit it's every time he
photo scans as always we've been using
photo scans in our videos for years
being able to just take some photos and
then after a few minutes get a pretty
good looking 3D model that I could then
just use for whatever I mean come on
that's a super power but here's the
thing photo scanning has always been
just a shortcut on the road to rendering
3D scenes a lot of effort is still
needed to set up the lighting and make
sure the scanned materials look correct
because out of the box they just never
do however some things are simply
impossible to scan
questions
I should probably not do that how do you
feel about photo scanning this
be impossible wouldn't it yeah yeah
there's too many Reflections this is not
gonna work why wouldn't it work photos
games rely on the pixels to be
consistent Chrome ball it changes every
single angle you look at it therefore
it's impossible to reconstruct
beautifully said did you try it oh I'm
about to yeah I don't know how it's
going to go it's gonna be weird it's
gonna be weird it's gonna be super weird
I'm looking forward to it me too
I processed the scans the table got
perfect look at these freaking chips
here look at these cookies however the
Chrome ball it's like a crunched up can
the photo scan didn't even try scanning
the bottle it just kind of got to it and
the parts that it could see that were
transparent it's like there's nothing
there photo scanning isn't Magic it's
math and when the math isn't perfect you
end up with unusable garbage I do not
know how Nerfs are supposed to solve
this though oh well I got a video for
you Sam
it's the end of this one when this one's
done and uploaded you can watch it and
you'll be like ah sweet uh yeah you guys
fast forward to that
now I'm going to take these same photos
and instead of processing them with
photogrammetry I'm going to process them
into a neural Radiance field I have no
idea how long
a lot of things I got to download and
install and uninstall and reinstall and
yeah I'll uh I'll make a Nerf
okay
I've made it through all of this all
afternoon
if this works
when I hit enter this will be my first
neural Radiance field
[Music]
okay okay I know these results are a
little janky it's kind of blurry there's
all these weird floating artifacts and
holes everywhere but the ball has
accurate Reflections it's even got the
transparency of the bottle so here's the
photo scan but here is the Nerf
after I tweeted out these results
freaking Paul Franklin of all people
responded that he could see a VFX
Revolution on the horizon and he knows a
couple things about VFX having won the
Oscar for best visual effects twice to
understand why visual effects artists
are excited about Nerfs we first need to
understand how light works the holy
grail for any CG artist is photorealism
to make an image so utterly realistic it
convinces your brain that it is real so
what is the secret to photorealism
Reflections if I was to ask you to point
out all of the Reflections in this scene
you'd probably point out the balloon
maybe the Bell or even the water but
look the white wall is bouncing back
some of the red of the painting in fact
every object is reflecting light from
every other object I mean think about it
everything we see is just light that has
reached our eyeballs now unless you're
looking directly at a source of light
it first has to reflect off of something
along the way so this was a trick
question because technically everything
we see is a a reflection because
Reflections are how we see stuff they
play a subtle but crucial role in
convincing our brains that stuff is real
check out this photo scan of some pans
now check out this Nerf of the same pans
see the difference as the camera moves
around the reflections change
realistically without having to add any
CG lights and that's because Nerfs rely
on neural rendering just like deep fakes
do it's able to learn what the color of
every point in a 3D space is depending
on where you're viewing it from and when
you have an entire field of these points
you end up with something that looks
shockingly similar to the photos used to
make the scan now let's compare the Nerf
to a real video and they look well they
kind of look the same because it was
literally trained on this exact video
and that is the entire point it's the
ability to quickly easily and cheaply
replicate reality in a way that looks
like video
ah this portion of the video is
sponsored by bones and all a new movie
coming out only to theaters this
Thanksgiving it's a new movie about a
couple young people who fall in love who
are also cannibals
[Music]
this movie stars Taylor Russell and of
course the Dune man himself Timothy
Charlemagne the story revolves around
Marin and Lee two Wayward kids trying to
find their place in society as they
Munch down on people they embark on a
liberating road trip as they try to
figure out what their place in society
really is because I mean where is the
place for people who eat people it is a
love story but it's also like a horror
thriller movie it's like bending these
genres like freaking Picasso the
performances are incredible the
cinematography is good the directing is
excellent It's directed by Luca
guadalino if you're a true Senate file
chances are you're gonna love this film
so check it out in your local theater
this Thanksgiving or go to bones and off
film.com to get tickets today once again
thanks to bunsenal for sponsoring this
section of the video now it's time to
get back to this crazy new scanning
technology my journey with the Chrome
ball started over the summer with
nvidia's instant Nerf program but I had
to learn a bunch of python coding and
use a command terminal just to get the
thing to run now however it's as easy as
using a phone app thanks to Luma AI it's
like polycam one of my other favorite
apps but it's for Nerfs you take a bunch
of different photos and you upload it to
their server a couple minutes later you
get back a Nerf it's great and it's easy
and it's fast but I need to be able to
import my own camera animation
separately and that's something I can
actually now do with the website version
of this app on my computer and that
opens so many doors and I'm gonna spend
the rest of this video walking through
some of them
apparently not that one
so I know what you might be thinking
what can you do with this new Nerf
technology well one of the more obvious
and easy things to do is just a simple
background replacement so Nico here is
standing in front of our X green screen
wall don't worry about it I'm going to
rhodo them typically most people when
they're shooting on a green screen the
camera is going to be locked off because
the background needs to match the
foreground and the moment you add motion
to everything you're gonna have a hard
time back
like me right now what we're doing here
with Nico is we're going to take the
camera out of the tripod and move it
around I'm going to be using by play
camera app to 3D track the scene as I
record the footage here and then I'll
replace the background and make them
look like he's anywhere I'm in a nerd
so another idea you can do with this
type of scanning Tech is like portals
what if this door turned into a portal
this is really a door to another world
so you first got to start by 3D tracking
your shot this is all pretty standard
then I can take that exact same camera
move and apply it to any Radiance field
that I want
whoa
whoa yo
what
oh man now it's a new one
how is this working
and if can I even peer through it
whoa no kidding
[Music]
sick
[Music]
oh wait where'd it go
I want to go back I just shot for 40
seconds this is a 40 second one take the
effect shot
[Music]
and it's not even a thing I mean it was
a bit of a thing but not too much but so
going back to the stuff I shot with Nico
here are a few things I learned I was
just having fun rendering out shots
because it was so easy just to take the
exact same camera move and drop it in
another scene whoa look at that wow what
a spot look at that that's crazy like I
put them on top of a mountain where I
like to go one-wheeling I put them in my
kitchen I put them in a garden at night
Nerfs work really well at night have you
ever tried photo scanning anything at
night it doesn't work it doesn't work
but this worked another thing is just
how subtle Reflections can really be I
know we talked about this earlier but
it's what makes all of this stuff just
sell so well is because the wall
slightly getting brighter when a
reflection gets a little bit more direct
to your eyes that's how light works it
just it looks like footage this better
look photo real otherwise I'm gonna be
disappointed the the camera just kind of
went through the geometry there a little
bit it's not geometry those aren't
polygons at all those are radiance
Fields lastly check out the shot of Nico
on my kitchen table next to a plant you
know a 3 3D camera move is still
something you can scale down or up and
that gave me an idea what if I scaled
the world down to make someone big
Ren could you scale me back down please
please or like scale the room up or
something I don't know how you did this
but I don't like it I'm gonna cost your
bowls it must go bigger bigger you don't
have to use your phone it's just based
off of images they can come from
anywhere so I'm gonna use my drone
what I'm looking to get here is I'm
basically trying to get a scan of that
big building so that I could then comp
in a shot of a person all big all right
I capture the Nerf now I gotta capture
myself so that I can 3D track this shot
and put it in the Nerf I'm gonna have a
spin around me
I'm King Kong
all right we got something there
oh
I am the king
of the world yeah
[Applause]
it sells the shot for me is of course
the lighting I captured both the plate
and the Nerf Outdoors at Golden hour and
the Nerf has captured all of that golden
Sunset goodness Pro tip if you want your
nerves and plates to match capture both
of them with the same lighting
conditions and ideally the same camera
as well so Nerfs gets you cheap
photorealism but it's not just any
photorealism it's a specific flavor
that's tuned to the camera that actually
captures it so I'm going to do an
experiment comparing the scans from a
red camera versus a webcam this is the
stupidest thing
I've ever done my theory is that one
scan will have a cinematic look and the
other scan will have a bit of a cheap
webcam look
yep that's exactly what I expected you
know we got compression dynamic range
the quality of your lens all of these
will have an impact on your finished
scan and speaking of cinematic the dream
of a gimbal operators get like the
smoothest most cinematic shots but
sometimes for whatever reason maybe
you're not able to get that sort of
smoothness you want so I'm gonna get the
most ridiculous camera move possible
here like this is not going to be a good
shot but the magic of Nerfs is that it
can do this
for comparison here's what warp
stabilizer did with a shot I'm also not
limited to simple camera moves either I
can get as complex as I want do you
remember Frozen Crossing Alpha
everyone's Frozen in time and the
camera's moving through that when they
needed to speed up the shot they would
take the footage and fast forward it but
then you get the
but if they were able to just do a
Radiance field scan of the whole thing
they could pick and choose their camera
moves after the fact
this is the nurse dude whoa your face
gets a little weird here up close oh
dude just a little bit smooshy can I
take this and extract geometry from it
still yes you can extract the geometry
but you lose all of the reflectiveness
because it all gets baked down into a
single diffuse texture and so that
texture then doesn't change as you orbit
around and view it from different spots
it's a little like you know being handed
the keys to a Rolls-Royce and then being
like sweet
I'm only going to need the hubcaps
um it's almost like you're leaving the
most valuable part behind exactly the
most valuable part of a Nerf is is the
actual neural render that's what you get
that photogrammetry doesn't give you
Nerfs are at their most powerful when we
treat them like video footage rather
than a scene to pull textures and models
out of but it does allow you to do
something cool like uh Collision
geometry for simulation yeah dude drop a
cloth on that now you're getting the
Best of Both Worlds you're still
utilizing the sort of photogrammetry
mesh of the whole scan but what we're
looking at is still the neural render oh
it'd be so sick if you could apply
motion blur inside of the Nerf program
and depth of field inside oh dude you're
totally right like it's so early days
the tools are so rudimentary feels like
I'm trying to carve a statue with other
rocks it's like technically I can get it
to work but it's just taken a lot of
pounding our head
it is literally 12 44 a.m right now
because this video needs to be done
tomorrow it's been difficult to explain
this to people with jaggy edges and
stuff it's kind of weird smeariness in
the background Columbus mushy this
better look better real otherwise I'm
gonna be disappointed why is your green
screen white see it's like it's not
about how perfect the results are right
now it's about the potential of these
results you know I have a very strong
belief that it's just a matter of time
before no one will be able to tell the
difference between a Nerf and actual
video I think I need one more shot
something to like really demonstrate how
crazy useful this new tech can be
huh
ah there it goes
yep I guess I'm not dreaming
[Music]
I think I know what our final shot's
gonna be
we're gonna try to do an Inception Shot
you know the shot and Inception when
like Paris folds over I'm doing one of
the kind of I'm doing a poor man's
interpretation of the very Advanced
effect but it's going to require like a
thousandth of the effort Ren are we
doing an Inception Shot because you're
trying to impress Paul Franklin I'm not
not doing that okay we don't really have
access to this spot so I'm just gonna
record a quick shot now to quickly get a
rebel scan the rebel scans has gotten
away from us this time
because of all the chaotic stuff going
on here if I wanted to actually shoot a
video it would have been too hard but
first time I was able to get a scan so
in theory I can go back and actually do
all the production filmmaking after the
fact
car
[Music]
together
and there you have it I hope at least
some of these ideas have inspired you to
pay attention to Nerfs I mean there's a
lot of potential here and I've just
barely scratched the surface it's our
job as artists to push this Tech as far
as it will go none of these shots in
this video were like production ready
but I hope that maybe they Inspire some
sort of nugget of an idea in you so that
you can get into this stuff as well and
push the bounds too of course I
recommend Luma it's what I've been using
for the majority of this video but my
buddy James helped me with nvidia's
instant nerfing in fact I think he has a
plug-in out that allows you to control
all of that stuff inside of blender and
also as of today polycam announced a
partnership with Nerf Studio there's
tons of options and if there's anyone
out there not yet convinced of the
potential of this new technology I
implore you to just look two papers down
the line to see where this Tech is going
it's exciting
what a time to be alive
we keep calling it Nerfs but I like to
point right now to change the names
I think a better more apps name would
you like deals
but it's still the same sort of thing
but in the end you're still getting
these things
use that name instead